well we believe the two ways have been
through multimedia on the one hand so
that's extending the brand and style of
content which we do in everything from
Playboy on Sirius radio to Playboy on
mobile but also via a licensing business
model into appropriate other products
and services that fit with the brand's
lifestyle and that's the rationale
behind doing the Playboy casino club at
the palms in las vegas or playboy retail
stores around the world to support our
playboy consumer products and i think
that many magazine brands do have a
lifestyle aspect to them and candidly I
don't think have perhaps as much
potential as playboy does because it is
such a strong consumer brand we do a
billion dollars at retail of just
consumer products but can do appropriate
whether it's events or other kinds of
products or services under their brands